今じゃあ肇社長ですというわけでみなさん iphone って言うかいますさ
でしょうか夜中僕が個人のは iphone 英文まっくすぷろーの最大スペックなん
ですけどもうそれが予約できなくてそれはおそらくかんですけどもそれでは別にですね
ちょっとやりたいことがありまして
一応です何とか iphone エイブルプロは変えましたーーー
こちらまでも一番欲しかった iphone 入れプロボックスに関しては重役ができ
たんでどちらも買えるかと思いますゆっくりこちらですね iphone
理論 pro
本当は512子が良かったんですけどなかったんで64 gb にしましたはい取り
ちょっと冊掛けてみましょう
がなんとぅ福祉さえも漆黒ですよしってっ
みてくださいこれがタピ岡根はですねまぁもちろん iphone イレブンすごいな
と思うんですけども僕がやりたいのですね別にこれの障害とかじゃなくて
皆さんもご存知の通り今回この iphone 入れるなぜがどうすごいかと言います
とですね間違いなければこの背面がカメラなんですよねこのカメラが3つになってるの
がマジでスゴいみたいな事を聞きました起動しました
光栄です
なんかちょっと重いですね僕ずっと iphone 10th max 使ってるん
ですけども
[音楽]
あぶな別に俺比較動画やりたいわけじゃないからねセット経由チューバさないからね
ぼく
[音楽]
れは去っすぐ iphone イレブンの世界を楽しんでいきましょう
アイア
こうですねはいたようで大フォンイレブン余裕セッティング看病しました
あーでやりたいことなんですけどもけばこの iphone イレブンの魅力って何か
と言いますとカメラなんですよ
次にスマートフォンにカメラが3台作りたいですよもうこれやばいんじゃないかなと
思いまして
今までの iphone の曲がまぁこんなことに1周がちょっと入れくれるんです
けども減ってるんですよもうそこの人形まで減っちゃいますからね
なにこれで by ちょっとあげるんだよはいねもう
オーバー広角カメラやばくないこの他どんな広いんだよってから広いんですけどそんな
すごいこのタピオカカメラなんですけども
こんなに逆広くて画像は綺麗だったら画像の容量やばいんじゃないかなと思いまして
ため今までのこの iphone の亀の湯で簡単に画像もいいから容量がすごい良い
と思うんですよなぜ今回ですねこの立てようかカメラで何ない写真を撮ったら64ギガ
の
iphone イレブンは容量がマックスになるのか検証していきたいと思いますこれ
とても役に立つと思います
もっともこんなにきれいだから目 iphone で写真撮り負けたいと思うんで
バグマンて超連射すると音です iphone イレブンでそんなに覚えるまで写真
撮ってるとすぐ夜マックになるんで果たし何がいけないけど写真までなってより甘くて
ならないのか写真と移籍でそろそろ消さないといけないんだけないなその基準がわかる
と思うんで金でそれを継承してい
たいと思いますでこの mi の新品で全く何も入ってないんでこのゼロの状態から
なんないなぁ戦でなきゃいけて写真撮りまくればよるまくせいなのかさっそく図って
いきたいと思いますでは以下
[音楽]
このまま税制が終わったらどうしようハイテクで早速満タンにしていきましょうもう現
時点で結構呼ぶが使われてるなぁスタートの時点から13切れてない使われてます
まあここあのサウンドの iphone にも必要だ余裕だと思うんでまぁこれは
仕方ないところだと思います様子ではタンスに沿っていきましょう
それでも全ボールの自撮りで埋めるぞ
[音楽]
なんだまで大きくなるんですけど
医薬市 bar バーストモードみたいなのなかったっけ
これだこれだこれしか夜にはもうまナースのお乳たーーー
[音楽]
me
ねえ悪いことせる十分だまあでも低調ですよねす課題です
bar たボード a 21待ってくださったんです
[音楽]
4スーツ小さい結構なペースで取れ言ってますよねー
実は30分にどれくらい余裕を見てみましょうかどんどんどうぞ
[音楽]
はいえーと今18分ねって10%アップで写真1000枚撮りました
結構ゼンマイのは余裕で取れるもんだからバスを使えば意外といける気がします持って
頑張ります
[音楽]
[拍手]
ずらーっ地きついぞこれみなさんが思ってる総合何杯は結構きつい強
写真こんな僕好きじゃないですかね
はい
すげー写真撮りペースが速すぎて時間差でどんどん写真が追加されていってますねそれ
にとって写真と僕もちょっとずつ移動しますよしがんばる8位
[音楽]
づらっほらっ
これやばいは狂いそう精神状態強くないことする気がしますねめっちゃ辛いです何か
自分とは何なのかわかんなくなってきますそんなに自撮りすることないもなって
[音楽]
[拍手]
快適ですね30分で撮った画像が数が3296マイですなんかバスト機能使うと伺った
スピードが上がりましたねあんなに電車しても一つの写真は撮ってるんでようでは結構
くれたのかなと思いますね性欲妻を買った瞬間この写真フォルダからねほんとに全部俺
うんはっはっは7結構なく広角の未来を感じましたねこれで大抵で30分とれ続けた
よーりを見てみましょうか
結構行ってるよペット要領で36.1 gb になっておりますちょっと挽きずに
頑張っています
えっ
[音楽]
はっはっは山ってこれちょっと
広角めっちゃさしんほりんですけど
me
だからここまで来るとシャッター音がながらレーザー光線の音みたいにプレイできます
強いもうシャッターをが
[音楽]
いいいいいい
祖母辛いまを持つたくな普通のこれ
ana
me
ran
さあだ自分が増えないと駄目だ駄目駄目だよね意識飛びかけてと思います
[音楽]
頑張れよもうすぐ1時間だからねぇ
バック着替えん
はい手続きを出しました亀甲さすがの iphone いるーむ暑くなってきました
これ精神的にマジでヤバイもう僕も様這わす全て僕でいいですかして容量ですねあと
50兄弟1 gb
いろいろ写真なんでもう品をなって全く頃その他っていうのはんちゃ3な気がしパン
また読み込んでるんだよなぁというわけで残り5ギガでございます
もうここまで来る打破へ来ない4を話していてそれ間の1時間とにパスでここまで来
るって相当やばい綺麗な画像ってことはそれなりにより送ってことですね
第2部に頑張っていきます
ソライロ
[音楽]
ええええええ
ています
あっ開いてカーきたぞはいと1分4秒でついに来ました iphone ずつ
レンジャーいっぱいデー
快適ですね iphone イレブンプロ行瞭然無事釣りで使うのにかかった時間は1
時間4分でした
俺一時間よく一人で自撮りしてなんですね
すげーだろうまず新規おかしくなるかと思いますが撮った写真の場合生なんですけども
合計なんと1万張って426ないでした
なんかこれ持ってるが不安なんですよなんかもういろいろバックてになったから動か
なくなっちゃって
これが楽しめますかわかんないんですもっと多いかもしれないんですけども発射
9000枚とか出ず
止まっててものが呼び込みをしないくらい多い状態になってしまいました
結局が動かなかったんですけど刷新ケース名古屋だったので中に標準そうでされた
まくりをたくさん消して例えば動くようになってましたけど iphone の
それぞれご覧くださいへ64日風61キーがすべてが写真のデータになっております
この会ファン写真しかありません全方位から写真とここ見ると82気が使用してまし
たって書いて
いうのも限界突破してるんですよねはい次で1時間8組んで表示上は1万8000枚
写真に撮るとたいファイル pro 64ギガはよいっぱいになるということが今回
わかりましたありがとうございますってことですよため128 gb で撮るの木時間
で iphone が止まって
土産御茶の木が立ったら4時間ないかまとまって512が経ったら初時間
釣りし負ければ止まるということが分かりましたみなさ
なぜやってみてねー
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ